rien un phénomène que j'observe de plus
en plus sur les réseaux sociaux et qui
me semble également très fréquent en
dehors des réseaux sociaux et qui est
peut-être l'une des raisons principales
pour lesquelles les débats se passent
souvent très très mal et ça vient du
fait que lorsque l'on est en mode débat
on a tendance à avoir certains objectifs
qui sont les objectifs du moment que
l'on a
parce qu'on a qui sont un peu instinctif
et qui sont pas nécessairement les
objectifs que l'on se mettrait si on
réfléchissait davantage à pourquoi
débattre ils vont voir la première vidéo
est l'un de ses objectifs qui me semble
extrêmement récurrent dans les débats
que l'on n'a en pratique une raison
empirique descriptive pour laquelle on
débat et qui me semble pas forcément
être une bonne raison de débattre et
nous sommes bien de mettre une très
mauvaise raison de les battre c'est ce
que je vais appeler l'appel à la meute
la paix la meute c'est quoi c'est le
fait que lorsque l'on débat on ce signal
comme appartement d'un camp en
particulier et on attend le support de
ce camp donc typiquement c'est ce qui
arrive beaucoup sur twitter lorsque on a
un commentaire sur avec lequel on n'est
vraiment pas d'accord et on va re tweeté
ce tweet mais avec un commentaire que
l'on ajoute typiquement dans le genre
regardez comment c'est scandaleux qu'une
personne puisse penser à la pointe elle
est finalement que tonton on fait ça on
attend on cherche pas absolument pas à
faire réfléchir tout le monde on n'est
absolument pas bienveillant envers les
personnes ni les personnes que l'on
critique ni personne de votre corps ni
même envers les gens de notre propre
camp lorsque l'on fait ça souvent c'est
avant tout pour avoir le support des
autres pour faire ce que j'ai appelé un
appel à la meute et bien sûr il ya le
côté appel à la meute dire quelque chose
pour avoir l'aval et le support de notre
clan ou d'un clan en particulier et il y
a aussi le fait de répondre à la mode
qui est tout aussi problématique parce
que bien sûr en retweetant et en laque
ans lors de commentaires on normalise ce
genre de façon de débattre qui me semble
extrêmement contre-productive notamment
parce qu'elle est absolument pas
bienveillante voir ce qu'on fait ça
quand ça absolument pas chercher le bien
des personnes avec lesquelles on
interagit sur ce moment là
pire que ça ça a tendance à stigmatiser
tout le monde a donné l'impression qu'il
ya un clan gentil incluant méchant qu'il
y a vraiment cette opposition cette
polarisation et qui va amener tout le
monde à avoir des réflexes très
instinctif ce qui est extrêmement
problématique lors surtout lorsqu'il
s'agit de sujets un tant soit peu
compliqué typiquement c'est le cas sur
toutes sortes de problèmes de société
qui enfin entre en jeu toutes sortes de
phénomènes sociologiques et de mouvement
de foule qui sont souvent extrêmement
complexe et long terme envers les
excellentes vidéo de mehdi moussaïd qui
parle des mouvements de foule et de voir
à quel point voilà il faut vraiment
étudier ça avec rigueur pour essayer de
mieux comprendre comment se comporte ce
genre de phénomène est malheureusement
avec les appels à la meute et les
réponses à l'appel à la meute on a
tendance à absolument pas favoriser un
débat de fond et on a tendance à
resté très très en surface et à énerver
tout le monde
et du coup à mettre en place des très
mauvaises conditions de débats donc il
me semble vraiment que de façon assez
générale ce phénomène d'appel à la meute
et de réponse à l'appel à la meute est
quelque chose qui soit très instinctif
c'est une raison pour laquelle on veut
débattre en pratique mais il me semble
aussi qu'il s'agit d'une mauvaise raison
de débattre et que si on réfléchissait
davantage on aura tendance à se dire que
c'est pas forcément les meilleures
façons de faire réfléchir tout le monde
et en particulier le camp opposé les
gens avec lesquels on est pas d'accord
les choses jambes on cherche à
convaincre
finalement donc voilà c'est une courte
vidéo sur un phénomène qui me semble
extrêmement récurrent est extrêmement
simple qui est le concept d'appel à la
meute
je pense que c'est une façon de faire
quelque chose un phénomène de société
qui est un peu négligé sur lesquels on a
tendance à pas prêter énormément
d'attention mais du coup je trouve ça
vraiment utile de mettre un mot dessus
le concept d'appel à l'alouette des
champs que c'est assez intéressant d'y
réfléchir un petit peu de voir quand
est-ce que c'est appliquer quand est ce
qu on envoie des appels à la meute
typiquement c'est ultra classique en
politique puisque finalement le rôle
d'un politicien c'est de faire des
appels à la meute puisse ce que son but
et rendent à grandir autant que possible
son électorat pour avoir un maximum de
supports et ensuite avoir un maximum
d'influencé
quel que soit son parti quelle que soit
sa position politique c'est aussi
quelque chose qu'on observe dans toutes
sortes de débats ddca un peu de
signalling qui est important on a
tendance à vouloir avoir le support de
beaucoup de gens et si on veut le
support de beaucoup de gens mais l'appel
à la meute est souvent la meilleure
façon d'y arriver
et du coup c'est quelque chose qui est
devenu traître est normalisée et je
pense que c'est assez problématique et
malheureusement aussi c'est un phénomène
assez négligent et on a tendance à pas
attacher d'importance que ça mériterait
je pense
et du coup je pensais avoir ce mot pour
désigner cette chose c'est quelque chose
de très utile donc vous inviter à
réfléchir un petit peu et peut-être
aussi à chercher de l'auto diagnostiqué
chez vous c'est de voir quand est ce que
vous faites un appel à la meute et quand
est ce que vous répondez un appel à m et
est ce que finalement c'est quelque
chose qui est vraiment productif pour
défendre les causes que vous voulez
défendre ou pour mieux réfléchir de
façon générale sur la situation
de la société d'aujourd'hui bref c'était
finalement une courte vidéo qui est une
sorte d'appel à faire attention à
l'appel à la meute j'espère que ça vous
fait réfléchir
j'espère qu'il ya quelque part dans le
cerveau quelque chose qui va résonner
avec ça qui va voir une petite réponse à
cet appel à l'appel à ne pas répondre à
des appels à la meute voilà je taime tu
as donné ta est en tout cas j'espère que
ça vous fait réfléchir sur comment mieux
débattre